Je te tiens, Danny,
accroche toi!
Non...
lâche moi John,
Sinon on y passe tous les deux.
Remonte-moi!
Mais lâche moi, de toute façon
tu tombes, t'es mort.
Fais pas ta pute.
-Meurs!
Remonte-moi!
Alors Mc Johns,
tu vois, tout était prévu,
c'est moi qui ai tué ton ...
Alors Mc Johns,
tu vois, tout était prévu,
c'est moi qui ai buté ton frère,
tu es mort Mc Johns!
Je suis Mc Johns
et je suis mort!
Hahaha.
Dwayne, whisky.
Une caïpirinha...
Une caïpirinha et un mojito!
On a plus de mojitos ici.
On y va.
Putain.
Ah putain.
Sinon ils bougent pas en fait?
Ben là ils sont sur place depuis longtemps,
on y va.
Puppy ?
t'as senti quelque chose?
Puppy, oh !
Tu fermes ta gueule!
Alors, on s'en sort?
Comme sur des roullettes.
Attention!
Bien joué !
Alors, on s'en sort?
Me parle pas sérieux,
me parle pas putain!
Non !
Dan !
Un gilet pare-balles?
Ow !
Dan ?
Un gilet pare-balles de tête.
Un Poncho par bal.
Je suis trop vieux pour ces conneries.
Dominique était trop vieux
pour ces conneries.
Sauter d'un pont en espérant tomber
sur un véhicule utilitaire
lancé à vive allure,
c'est impossible
parce qu'on n'est pas dans un film
Putain!
Amen.